(audience cheering)
- All right, let's finish up
with something super touching,
trending on social media.
This is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat music)
(crowd applauding)
As a mama,
I know how easy it is
to get lost in the chaos
of everyday life.
You're so busy doing,
that you're not always taking the time
to check in emotionally.
So I've heard,
but I also know how important it is
to sit down for quiet time
with my kiddos and reflect.
Especially if any of
us have had a hard day.
That's why I so appreciate
this conversation
that Canadian mama recently had
with her four-year-old son, Aldie.
(screen swooshes)
- But, but earlier,
I chose to be a tiny bit mad.
But, but, after a while,
I was okay.
- You were okay?
We get upset.
We get mad.
We cry.
- That's emotions, Mama.
Even when you're upset or angry.
- Mm-hm.
- Always different kinds of feelings.
(screen swooshing)
(audience clapping)
- I mean,
Aldie should write a book.
We have little Aldie and his mama, Jonisa
on the line right now watching on Citytv.
What's up, Jonisa?
What's up, Aldie?
(audience cheering)
- Hi Kelly!
- Oh, I like your truck, Aldie
That's a cool truck.
So Jonisa, do you and
Aldie chat like this a lot?
- Yeah, I try to have bedtime
conversations every night
with my kids so they can communicate
with me and express how they feel
or what they want.
But I don't record it
except that night.
Cause it was different.
Earlier that day,
he had a hard time.
And so I was setting him up for bedtime
and he started talking about it
and so I captured that moment.
Yeah, he's, he's very wise for his age.
Like I keep thinking
like, how old is this kid?
You know?
Cause those little things like,
when I'm stressed and,
like, I raise my voice
and he would remind me to,
"Mama, stop.
Breathe slow and make a smart choice."
It's amazing.
- Oh my gosh!
I love it.
He's like a life coach.
So Aldie, what are your favorite emotions?
Do you like talking about
your emotions with your Mama?
- Everything,
even when you are mad, sad, upset,
I always like talk to my Mom.
Thank you Mama.
(audience coos)
Thank you for being my Mama.
(audience claps)
- [Jonisa] Aww. (laughs)
- I think I just became
pregnant, like. (laughs)
Like, I just want a baby now. (laughs)
Like, I was like, wait, what?
Oh my gosh.
That literally was my favorite thing
to ever happen in the four seasons
I've been a part of this show.
Aldie, you just broke my heart
in the most amazing way.
Anyway, thank you for sharing this video
and also thank you for being honest
cause all us mamas and daddies,
we all lose our patience
because we're human.
And it's just nice to
have those around you
to kind of bring everything
back into perspective.
Even if it's coming from
a tiny person. (laughs)
I am loving your post right now.
Bye Aldie!
(heart dings)
(audience claps)
And that's, that's actually not all,
our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Friction, the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
creating strong bonds
with their kids just like you, ma'am.
So, they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Wow! Thank you!
(Kelly laughs)
- A thousand dollars?
- [Jonisa] Yeah. (laughs)
- A thousand dollars.
Look, he's so cute.
Alright, bye y'all have a good one.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Ali Wong, Cassandra
Freeman, Mika Brzezinski,
Tracy and Nancy, y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.